à trois mois du jour j -p en question de
changer la date du scrutin
en réponse à une décision de la cour
fédérale qui lui demandaient plus de
détails
le directeur général des élections
réitère son refus dans un document de 12
pages
stéphane pérou écrit je reconnais que la
tenue de l'élection le 21 octobre
signifie que les électeurs juifs
pratiquants doivent voter d'une autre
façon ils ont toutefois la possibilité
réelle de participer au processus
électoral les électeurs juifs
pratiquants qui ne pourront se déplacer
dans un bureau de scrutin le 21 octobre
devront donc voter autrement
le centre consultatif des relations
juives israéliennes rappelle que ce ne
sont pas les options qui manquent
alors donc 4 août façon de voter par
anticipation par la poste au bureau du
directeur de scrutin de la
circonscription et dans les institutions
postsecondaires et ce sont ces quatre
autres façons de voter qui doivent être
mieux connu pour encourager la
participation électorale le directeur
général des élections s'engagent à
augmenter ses effectifs dans les bureaux
de votes des circonscriptions qui compte
au moins 1 % d'électeurs juifs il y aura
sous peu une campagne d'information
destinée précisément aux gens qui ne
pourront pas voter le jour de l'élection
la question des accommodements religieux
demeure délicate et les politiciens sont
prudents on va continuer d'écouter les
avis du directeur des élections par
rapport à quand cette sélection devrait
obtenu c'est toujours là
la responsabilité des coups durs 6,6 et
le directeur général des élections de
gérer cette question donc je laisse la
décision dans l'armée seul le chef du
bloc québécois yves françois blanchet se
réjouit ouvertement de cette décision
changer la date d'une élection générale
aurait constitué tout un casse-tête pour
élections canada alors que l'organisme
emploie 300 mille travailleurs
temporaires répartis dans 16 mai le
bureau de vote
cette affaire derrière lui le dge peut
maintenant consacrer tous ses efforts
encourager la participation des 27
millions d'électeurs canadiens ici
mathieu gaye et radio canada ottawa